cancel the canceling true Jordi's true
news this Bart ladies and gentlemen the
way it works
all these canceled yeah cancel this
check them at this isn't actually merch
by the way I just seen it and thought
could be I saw a word on a cap and I
thought I could be mine that probably
wouldn't be what I'd have on on my heart
after recent events maybe something no
Scott man to get it this was actually a
tune though that's right I mean no
wonder you like it but I'm not no he's
not just a real array after last week on
the Conor McGregor time for true news
though the tights yes sorry
[Music]
just last week TMZ posted a video of an
incident that occurred back in April of
this past year can you tell us your side
of that story what happened there well I
would love them to attend one when you
refused the drink of me Irish proper 12
so I slapped the [__] piss out what
do you think happened II then pulled the
bottle up and went a drink of this fine
whiskey in reality it doesn't matter
what happened there I was in the wrong I
liked the fact that you were in reality
it doesn't matter it's like as if as if
to say well there is a bit of a story
it's like me refused the drink we can
see that clearly Paul though isn't it
because he sort of also goes in reality
it doesn't matter it's like no in
actuality and reality it doesn't know
definitely that man deserve to enjoy his
time in the port without having having
it to end the way it did
can I just say though but for those
wondering how I ended it ended with the
man continuing his drink reality was he
just continued drinking as normal
McGregor didn't bother him carried on do
you know I thought was awkward yeah I
think Connor left the pub thinking left
him on the floor the old man just went
the old man went home to his wife about
10 o'clock you know I mean he had his
normal Goods so he gets back into us he
goes no I mean that one fella what's his
name kana kaanum whatever he came in
tried to start so I told the shove he's
[__] whiskey up he's ours
didya stops it yeah oh yeah five months
ago it was and I tried to make a man's
and I made a man's how do you made
amends imagine though Connor comes over
and he goes I'll sort you out and the
guys like I just wanna be absolutely
clear Connor you sending me money not
whistle all right I [__] hate that
must come here before you and take
accountability and take responsibility
and I owe it to the people for me to
believe that this apology is genuine and
I'm not saying that dawn but fully
believe it
I wonder your connemara talked like he
normally talks as and he a lot of this
sounds like stuff that people have told
him to say like come here before you
doesn't sound like him does that make
sense why is he speaking like a knight
of the realm
yeah do you know I come here before yeah
before you might came yeah and I offer
you I owe it to the people who trained
me in martial arts that's not that's not
who I am that's not the reason that's
not the reason why I got into martial
arts
our study in combat sport it's like
word-for-word the [__] I would say to my
video against him he's actually sort of
speaking I wonder if we see in the 3.2
million view video I did well he's just
one viewer though so you never know what
to say there was one hundred and twenty
thousand likes on that it's a sea of
them I got no money for it I said that's
a great thing to monetize Doug you
YouTube I don't want to go on I have
been making steps and continually making
steps to do better and be better and
it's like a dagger into my heart as a
young martial artist so he's just
talking [__] now it's like a dagger into
my heart yep alright if you are being a
better person then don't go into buying
threaten an aunt man you didn't threaten
them he followed through I'm all right
Connor sorry back to being a fanboy
sorry the video is a little grainy did
you in fact punch that man yeah look in
respect to the whole entire situation
I'm just a simple yes or no will do
Ariel Helwani has to follow this up now
if you're asking a question like that as
a journal you got to nail him down did
you punch him or not although it's
crystal [__] clear what happened was
a little hazy for me also on and where
was many months ago like I said and I
have been making a man stood right is he
now saying I don't remember lonely
months ago many I'd love it if he knew
it wouldn't the only thing we were to
talk about if he did if he gone it was
mainly I'd love him that was hammered no
idea I would love that reality honestly
just be like I was so off me [__]
tits man just let me clear as a final
Conor McGregor made a lot of mistakes
I don't anyone's expect them to be a
perfect role model we're not asking
Anthony Joshua yeah we all know we're
not getting that this needs to be a
beginning of a journey now for Conor
McGregor and even if that journey
doesn't end in him in an octagon are
fighting for a title or win in a fight
or any of that but just to be a better
block this needs to be the beginning of
you've been rumbled you're acting like a
piece of [__] stop doing it and sort
your [__] head and that's it right
message no you know I'm true Jodi and I
approve this message kind of excited see
I'm not sure all right
Joanie's also again right here could
this time no James Charles bottom so it
does look a bit odd that considering the
lack of muscularity in his body and then
he's got quite a sort of muscular ass
but his legs aren't small I did this
looks like it's being fought or shopped
a bit be honest for you funny how his
leaks
look like that mine not so great if I'm
honest with you make you look like right
hit me look like an ass yeah I mean I've
seen losses with less I mean right
what well for a bloke Hoss it's not bad
if I was in prison and James Charles was
me sell me eventually I'd probably gone
and I mean I'm talking about 10 years
everyone's pointing guns Yeah right ten
minutes I'm serious it would take a
while yeah but at some point I'd be like
when you when you're bored of jacking
off you would in the end go Palace
trying well the thing about James
Charles is he could talk to me because
he sounds like a good girl so that'll
probably do it for a while I forgotten
how James Charles sounds very do you
think you've having sex with James
Chelsea so he goes hey guys welcome back
yeah like he's a virgin apparently so
cause he'll well I don't know apparently
he's done some stuff but not the whole
way all right
he hasn't had it in that Wow this is
ethan klein not quite as nice if i'm
honest really people like i suffer
Ethan's content
I prefer James Charles's ass right I
prefer Ethan's or or another word for
bottle no genuinely I'm gonna say that
is funny but what a difference because I
tell you what if Ethan was my soul mate
you'll be safe you know what if anything
you need to thank [__] James Charles
because he really took the heat off you
last week I actually DM them I was like
bro if you've got any news you can
release right now that would really
[__] help me out CJ I got this I got
this Johnny who sought you out no
problem and then II started damning me
stuff I was like no no tweeted I don't
miss I don't want to see this yeah I
don't want seen worse yeah and then
Brian I've looked through them tweet
this one i photoshopped the answer bit
bigger i cropped out the [__] and I was
like right you got the gore release the
new release the hounds Alex wasabi got
killed by fouseytube that's the one
Spicer punch is that his actual hair
like no I think he's has you had to
touch I'm one you saying that because it
looks too good the lion is - right like
it needed to be a bit more we're so in
fact they's head is completely shiny
oh he hates that job considering Fuzzy's
the one who's being training he walked
straight and fuzzy by the way their
rumour in that he could fight Jake Paul
on the ksi log and undercard because
Fugees got ten million subs Jake needs
someone with a comparable audience sure
size wise about the same so we're
judging this year yeah I think Jake's
gonna get the better of him yeah no [__]
his foot had fabric and head movement
and exit like Jake has basic
understanding general I mean like right
now that would be too much for him Alex
wasabi isn't doing too bad yeah knowing
that fuzzy wins this I'm left wondering
how fuzzy is noticeably getting drained
from all these punches he's taken like
you can see it in his face I don't know
if you've seen that before he's thrown
with bad intentions though wow it was
he's walking him down there's this kid
here you see what he's doing here this
is what happens when really
inexperienced people get into a boxing
ring so they just stop using their arms
they're not turning or anything like
that right just wasted energy arms just
try you start to panic yeah you stop
punching with all your arm but you're
not going to generate enough power just
a nominee to turn your whole body into
it and that's he's showing that he just
doesn't know what he's doing basically
and when you get in a boxing ring and
you don't know what you do and don't
have people around with cameras he's
done in that job though ready face punch
there Oh up and he's running away now oh
yeah oh yeah he turned into it as well
Wow from what I've seen him Alex wasabi
if he knew anything he would have
[__] done well in this so he was he
was having a lot of success
who's he looks as shocked as everyone
else he's like do not just do this [__]
I think that was in good spirits they
didn't it wasn't too aggressive I think
the spirits change when JJ steps him
now Brian you might remember some cheeky
little Christians that appeared on the
channel not long ago
well you're invited too radical purity
God's work has powerful truth and
practical answers to help human race
purity in your everyday life and we
found a way to monetize it so that you
pay us to say things that are already in
a [__] book oh my god guys it's
already in a [__] book you could read
yourselves but instead we're gonna
pretend you need us
where's it going with this radical
purity Brian what is that purity
I thought you if you're religious you
just pick up a book and read it and sort
of live by the rules join us for our
upcoming girls conference radical purity
embracing God's best in the midst of a
highly seductive culture maybe this is
well being going wrong I'm starting to
wonder Brian if you know what radical
purity I've swapped radical purity for
radical filth
yeah I wish you'd shower if anything you
are one of the cleaner people that's Ron
actually one of the cleaner people that
I know I shower regularly
I've got all the dirty [__] I'm getting
although she does look good there on the
right there she's a good-looking woman
what can you say even if she is like
talking [__] yeah this is another one of
our videos Brian called how to be
content when your heart's desire is
unfulfilled by your dildo
whoa yeah that's it sorry different yeah
she's just so pretty I can't get all our
pretty it's annoying though because I
want to dislike her but then she's
talking I'm like there's a lot of people
that would just look at these two girls
and just fall in love with the whole
thing wouldn't they like being users
poster girls to be like draw people into
the so this is the guy who nabbed her
he's an average joe's well any faith
[__] plate or Amalia I do was read
his Bible shows where often and you
write things actors Kristen's nails and
Roxy what's up guys it's Kristen and Zak
and we wanted to give you guys a little
bit of an inside peek into our lives he
is punching he is punishing so hard he's
a good Christian man if your hairline is
receding oh I mean my hairline is
clearly there yeah if it is going that
way its own jelly look like don't do
that don't make you
get her nails done elsewhere yeah we
kind of not be as good as I wanted this
is coming from me you're a sick freak
all right you're worrying about her
fingernails what is wrong with you how
many women get home to their husband
MouseMan goes you've been to that
goddamn now sometime that nail place
again what what have you done I told you
I told you last time honey
they don't do you any favors okay all
right when I fell in love with the UFC
there was one fighter in particular who
this early on he fought in Newcastle
called BJ Penn he's from Hawaii greatest
light weight of all time pretty much
like that was what he was known for he
went up and fought George st. Pierre
even though he'd probably belonged
nowhere near the man's weight just
controlling people you know he just
keeps getting in fights outside of the
he's on like a seven fight losing streak
in the UFC which worst of all time
saying that just keeps letting him fight
even though he's clearly done is he not
look good in the fight eyes it's like
watching Roy Keane all of a sudden come
back and play for money make it now
we're like what are you doing you want
to see him commentating the fights you
want to see him giving his expert
analysis you want to see him held up as
a legend to the spot in the whole of it
like you want to see him doing well
after his times over no Idol in the
street going hmm
it's just embarrassed on me so he's
fighting some random fat guy y'all
should be going and to be fair the fat
guys form is poor no he's not out check
this out check this out fat guy with a
shirt off
knocks him clean Oh a UFC legend I'm not
he's like one of the greatest ever we're
not talking about just some random guy
who fat man in the street just dropped
him like a bad habit you know I mean
like he's making McGregor look great
right now yeah he really is no it's just
sad you know I mean like you you want
legends to go off into the sunset and
have a great life and sometimes people
can't let go of the game yeah brave
parents though calling BJ
[Music]
all right let's roll he's a [__]
madkin he has time that perfection the
way it comes off oh yeah perfectly can
we watch oh good can I just say there
are times where I've had no credit for
the camera work that I've done but
you're watching this and [__] you
literally just went kaput but of the
future and combined it with a beer no
well what [__] me up the most about
this yeah is that this music goes better
with him and with but the food on his
Twitter it just says alcoholic living on
the door yeah honestly he makes me feel
so nervous he's a car guy that you get
stuck at a like a [__] barbecue with
and your mate goes oh let me um meet
bootleggers and then they go I need to
go and cook some stuff and then you're
just stood there while he goes he's like
in 1940's gangster yeah she um I'm going
out erection there's gonna be seven
thousand of us you better watch your
backs
the poor and we've got a spaten up to
over fish by the excitement on his face
for the extra few points of alcohol is
amazing do you know what I really want
to do I really want to put him and blue
van man in a room and see if they get on
or not I feel like universe would not
employ
I think I'm the opposite and I know blue
bar mom would be all for this I don't
want them in a room I want them in a
ring I'm talking about the wrestling
ring Oh WrestleMania main event blue VAR
man versus the bootlegger because all I
see is blue VAR man just shooting star
press just flying across the ring slams
into them pins and for the three-count
we have a chump go glues on man would be
the whole Cogan or the the Stone Cold
Steve Austin do you know I mean leave a
man's not a place he is the babyface
yeah he is the bad one too gold dust
over not called us he's more of a
pallbearer ambassador flux capacitor
sounds like something off of Em's or the
ponal version of but what's that it's
the flux capacitor yeah what does that
do it just puts sperm everywhere into
the future in the past man and that's
just people in the past again we've
taken imagine I don't know say your
school teacher not that I would do this
but like she's telling you off and then
next thing you know you're stood on top
of the desk and just shove your [__] in
her mouth right yeah I really do love it
there was nothing to do with time travel
in that it's not you just literally went
suddenly just shoving your [__] in her
mouth and I was like have you
time-traveled today this is a wonder
where Mari and gore sometimes isn't it
moving on naked Martin is his name opens
up about stag party that spiked and
assaulted him he looks like one of your
myths sort of dad's or something doesn't
he yeah you know when you're going over
and they go she won't play football in
the garden is your dad around what my
naked dad yeah is he around your little
bald hairy chested naked dud yeah Martin
loves his newfound career as an adult
entertainer
he's like sort of like you know when men
get certain kinds of girls to strip for
them as a joke right this is another
part yeah right without that for female
stoke what am i minutes did stripping
month so though what was it like using
that much for it I bet they are no but
he was like 21 year old at the time I'm
like [__] me me you've got some balls on
you only as I put the whipped cream on
his [__] and they're all like sucking it
off and all that camco his brave guy it
all went very badly wrong on a stag
doing RB fuh it beats her for Americans
in June when Martin was assaulted spiked
I don't know what spiked means seeming
like the other gonna put this into girls
drink however and left choking on his
own vomit speaking to lad Bible Martin
said the stag was sat on us seats with
his back to me and I have my green
mankini on and the guy said would you
just go up and hug him
from behind so I did that and he turned
around and punched me right in the face
I went flying on the floor he then went
and smashed a statue as well in the
midst of turning around the statue was
probably one of those Greek gods
yeah and he looked at him and thought
that reminds me of him I'm gonna hit
that as well this guy was a homophobe
yeah yes naked men are fab yeah exactly
anyway I'm not gay not just about my
nose which wasn't very nice Wow then my
nose felt really weird it was kind of
like a sharp feeling yeah I start on the
barstool and within 10 minutes I lost
the he's terrible for a naked man I'm
thinking about looking at a naked man
with Jenny I couldn't even focus
properly and I remember one of the hotel
staff asking who was going to pay for
the study that was can you imagine that
you're naked having just been forced to
do ketamine and a hotel staff member
comes over and goes excuse me sir yes
sir I know you're busy right now but I
hate for their can ask you any there's
not a lot going on it haven't got a
wallet in there yeah I'm gonna need some
money we need someone to pay for statue
that's all I'm thinking now Brian you're
a big movie fan but you're also a big
bat is Batman your favorite superhero I
want your favorite superhero movie
probably the Dark Knight
I think I like the movie of Dark Knight
Rises better as a whole overall movie
sure but yeah Heath Ledger as the Joker
was the best performance in a superhero
movie ever the bars pretty [__] law
because superhero movies are dog [__]
generally controversial
and he just went on super don't like I
think if Heath Ledger sadly had have
lived then it would have completely
redefined the world who saw him as an
actor like this would have you changed
the right so basically right now we're
left with sort of Brad Pitt and Leonardo
DiCaprio Heath Ledger was well on his
way of becoming the next guy Brokeback
Mountain all of that he was on a level
he was the next Daniel day-lewis kind of
thing after this I saw that sort of
thing nailed it that's the [__] in it
like you though the so [__] side it's
saw they've redone the Joker as a movie
so they've done an origin story for the
Joker which isn't really attached to any
other movie it's just sort of exists as
though Batman is not in this I don't
believe so no I mean you
never know who's not seeing the film but
it's not alluded to it's literally just
all about his descent into madness it's
Joaquin Phoenix playing him yeah who was
amazing and gladiator one of my favorite
movies was one of his original way got
his big break from what I remember to
die for so the star is Nicole Kidman and
she basically gets a young Joaquin
Phoenix to fall in love with her and
they're like murder foreigner exactly in
1995 kind of film isn't it like it's
what I grew up on it's a real name under
95 should we watch him in the jaw Yeah
right there I have some bad news for you
this is actually also a parallel to the
life of bootleggers
[Music]
I like the font and outright it's very
rare that you and I agree on fun so like
we were always like we just hate most
fun stories yeah yeah we've done a lot
of fun watching
[Music]
really existed so much of being the Joe
F from the Heath Ledger side of things
was his body language and how we like
flails is arm like I like what I'm
saying so far yeah 30-plus years of
service oh my god I knew that you would
love this name of film dangerzone kenny
loggins kenny rogers i hope they don't
remove the homoeroticism from this one
because you know it was the compass sort
of movie isn't it I mean who plays
volleyball in jeans yeah
realistically you probably couldn't fly
like these kind of planes for that long
of a career could you I mean your nerves
would be shot this [__] yeah sorry I
forgot that you were somehow a military
expert wow that does look amazing
either that or it sharpens the senses
Brian that would [__] me up you know I
couldn't handle it idak I had a friend
who wanted to be in the I love how
you've just had to got me for claiming
to be a military expert and your claim
the military is I had a friend who
wanted to be in the in the what is this
piffle yeah I thought the YMCA this is
how you take a baby panda off an adult
panda here from the Apple smart this
panda now forgets look at the baby panda
yeah how take him take him away just
give me the [__] Apple yeah give me
the Burger King this is like a Burger
King - yeah and mine does a struggle
over breed no wonder this [__]
picture
they're losing their kids although maybe
that's what happened to the Mekons er
just give them an apple has no not sure
what sorry
oh all right well then see ya see ya
blue van man has been on holiday we've
come to donate because we can you can
move the camera to look at the houses if
you want to that's directing isn't it
he's no shouting things out for her as
if to say oh there's this what he's in
is you've got a [__] putting the
camera in the right direction come on
June but people walk in here with dogs
Oh are they going doggin yeah I like how
she goes yeah yeah you've got a watt in
the boss just filming the boss blue van
man is full of Filth nowadays am i
rubbing off on yes I think you are
actually I mean don't rub off on him
directly but inside the van again folks
here look you want me no steering cover
I was thinking about changing the
steering wheel I remember once we had we
did a podcast with Alfie deyes where he
said I'm never gonna go out of my way to
do anything just for the camera I just
want to film what happens right this is
the zenith of that ultimate yeah this is
what Alfie deyes just sold out of B yeah
all of those years we found it blew my
mind Alfie if you're watching and your
big mansion and Brighton or wherever it
is you wish you up do you you wish you
would do not only do you'll never ever
be here right you've influenced a
generation of filmmakers Alfie
absolutely yeah he's got a cap on you're
doing it a week after here's who's
influencing whom who started it start
from the bottom over here to Krusty's
with there are so many people out there
who actually though I think all have you
seen peaky blinders anything yeah
when was the first series of peaky
blinders June what we in 2090 said was
near 40 something like that they're just
saying years now this is what what year
was it out 2012 2013 2014 Thank You June
I love it Oh blue van man I love you
he's put it on backwards he's a little
Cool J that he looks like samuel
l.jackson a little bit if he starts like
pushing his lips I locally yeah all
right that's enough for a day of true
news I'm so everyone who watch today
thanks everyone for all your support
messages and all that [__] I've had
lately thanks a lot I didn't say
everything's fine don't worry about
little Oh true Geordie I'm not going
anywhere [__] and if you can
like the video and subscribe
really appreciate it now we're gonna
watch the rest of this and have some
bigger Cheers